[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en el
nuevo ciclo que se abre en el Vaticano a
partir de la muerte del Papa Benedicto
16 y los retos que le quedan por delante
del Papa Francisco en lo que le queda el
papado para analizar todo ello nos
acompañan en este estudio tres invitadas
Mary lord Sara docente investigadora
experta en estudios latinoamericanos
bienvenida marilol Buenos días gracias
por su invitación
compañera de la redacción de recibí
bienvenida Hola qué tal y lamia
Guadalupe periodista independiente
autora del libro Jesús te ama La ola
evangélica bienvenida la mía Hola Es un
gusto estar aquí con ustedes y en duples
también nos acompaña nuestro
corresponsal desde Roma Federico googlia
bienvenido encantado estar con ustedes
nuevo ciclo en el Vaticano en nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
la muerte del Papa emérito Benito 16 el
primer papa que renunció al Cargo en
siete siglos dando lugar a una insólita
convivencia entre dos papás deja un
panorama incierto en el futuro de la
iglesia con múltiples interrogantes para
lo que le quede de papado a Francisco el
auge de posturas ultrareligiosas que
intentan marcar agendas políticas
ultraconservadoras en varios países la
pérdida de fieles en un granero como era
América Latina en favor de los
evangélicos los casos de pederastia pero
también tensiones entre corrientes de la
iglesia conservadoras y progresistas al
menos en la jerarquía la pregunta que
hay de fondo de todo esto es cómo
revertir la pérdida de influencia de una
institución como la iglesia hay un
cambio de ciclo demográfico que afecta
también a la religión muchos analistas
apuestan a que el sucesor de Francisco
podría llegar desde Asia o de África
muestra del sentido de revulsivo que
estaría buscando el Vaticano repasemos
algunas portadas de prensa
dialola dedicaba esta portada Benedicto
16 por su muerte a los 95 años dice que
pasa la historia por su condición de
teólogo y por su llamativa renuncia que
pilló por sorpresa la iglesia una
renuncia que en su momento fue recogida
por portadas como esta del periódico en
2013 tira la toalla entre los retos de
esta etapa para la iglesia está la
pérdida de fieles artículos como este
del diario El Mundo retratan como la ola
de evangélicos se expande por toda
América Latina la pregunta que se hace
la iglesia es mayor si el caso del Papa
recién fallecido podría repetirse o si
habrá
una especie de Caso único que hará
Francisco y cómo encara lo que le quede
de papado Yo creo que el Papa Francisco
Es una posibilidad que le queda
efectivamente ha dicho que si le
abandona las fuerzas es algo que puede
hacer sin embargo lo que no quería él es
que hubiera dos papas eméritos ahora es
una posibilidad pero está en buena salud
mejor salud digamos que Benito 16 a la
misma edad porque cuando renunció 16
tenía su edad el i el antecedente
impulsa el debate es decir que hace un
señor de 85 años como Francisco al
frente de una institución que necesita
revitalizarse nos podríamos preguntar yo
creo que el papa Bueno ese es mi opinión
personal yo creo que él no se pone esa
pregunta él él también él dice Bueno hay
ciertas reformas que él empezó muchas
reformas que empezó y bueno va a seguir
adelante en silla de ruedas o no y este
o sea conociéndolo no creo que va a ser
igual que el papá benedito pero de qué
manera etcétera No lo sé yo no tengo una
bolita de cristal para decirlo no sé uno
de los principales retos que te le
quedan a Francisco por delante la mía es
sobre todo recuperar el terreno de
influencia el terreno perdido en lo que
antes era un granero de fieles como era
América Latina ya el título de su libro
es claro Jesús te ama La ola evangélica
vamos a ir descubriendo a lo largo del
programa los factores fundamentales que
han impulsado esa ola evangélica Bueno
de hecho los evangélicos llenaron un
vacío tienen una acción con los más
pobres con temas como la violencia
doméstica las el alcohol y están muy
presentes en las favelas las vías
meseras dependiendo de cómo se llaman
América Latina entonces De hecho hay la
Iglesia Católica ya no está en estos
lugares y la pregunta es ahora Cómo
volver si es aún posible o como de hecho
trabajar en esta situación luego nos vas
a contar más cosas sobre ese proceso de
cómo ha ido rellenando los huecos que
había dejado el catolicismo muy
interesante en los evangélicos
corresponsal en Roma Federico Google nos
preguntamos la muerte del Papa Benedicto
16 cierra un periodo histórico en la
iglesia cómo queda ahora esa batalla
soterrada entre la corriente
conservadora y la aperturista el grito
de batalla Se oía después de pocas horas
de la muerte de Benedicto su secretario
personal padre Georg declaró a un diario
alemán que la medida tomada el decreto
en el 2021 tomado por Francisco para
limitar el uso del latín en la misa fue
algo que le rompió el corazón a lo dijo
textualmente este tema es un tema muy
digamos que no es el tema solo de
padreguero es de todos los conservadores
y no es un detalle el latín es una raíz
de la Iglesia Católica apostólica y
romana Por otra parte la corriente
progresista o reformista siempre dijo
que Benedicto era el papa del no no
entendía la modernidad no entendía los
problemas sociales cuando era sobre todo
el brazo derecho de papa boitila fue
contrario a la a los teólogos
aperturistas en América Latina
combatieron junto con papa huitila la
teología de la liberación estas son dos
caras que siempre estuvieron en la
iglesia la novedad es que esta vez el
conflicto es más claro y que los
conservadores no reconocen a Francisco
la voluntad y la capacidad de ser el
resumen de las dos caras de la iglesia
Ya ven que a lo largo del programa vamos
a ir tratando las diferentes aristas que
tiene este nuevo ciclo abierto en el
Vaticano los retos de Papa Francisco El
antecedente de Benedicto XVI y marilor
le pregunto a propósito de lo que nos
contaba el corresponsal la tensión entre
las dos partes de la iglesia es una
imaginación o está apoyado en datos es
decir este hecho que larvado entre
aperturistas y el sector conservador
Hasta qué punto hay literatura Hasta qué
punto de imaginación Hasta qué punto hay
Netflix Y hasta qué punto hay realidad
Bueno yo no estuve en el Vaticano pero
por ejemplo decía que fue el
corresponsal de la afp en el Vaticano
habla de esto es una realidad sin
embargo yo creo que ahí hay caricaturas
también es decir que una corriente
conservadora siempre la hay lo que pasa
es que efectivamente hay hay una
tradición que
se rompió un poquito con él con Vaticano
segundo y hay gente que quiere seguir
con la corriente anterior ahora hoy en
hay otra corriente que se vuelve más
tradicionalista o más conservadora
porque ve que hay como una pérdida de
valores y quiere recuperar estos valores
y esto se ve Incluso en católicos
jóvenes Entonces el papa tiene que
tratar de manejar todo esto y la postura
de Francisco es interesante es tratar de
integrar la diversidad dentro de una
universalidad lo que hizo también
Benedicto 16 porque tenía la mano hacia
Los partidarios de monseñor loffet
consumo tu propio de 2018 pero luego
Francisco puso el veto por ejemplo a
tendencias más conservadoras como las
del cardenal Sara en Guinea que quiso
por ejemplo volver a una misa incluso
dando la espalda a los fieles Y eso para
Francisco no es posible hay límites
de la iglesia lamia quería insistir
sobre algo hoy cuando se habla de
conserva uno piensa en la agenda de
género matrimonio igualitario y todo hay
también el tema económico y por ejemplo
en América Latina fue eso lo más
importante O sea la tecnología de la
liberación cuando perdió en América
Latina era la acción social de los
padres de los obispos y todo y en aquel
entonces que sea el Papa Benedicto o
Juan Pablo antes la idea era la lucha
contra el comunismo Entonces no era
tanto el tema de estar contra el aborto
esto siempre fue y al final no cambió
tanto pero lo que sí ha cambiado es eso
es pensar podemos ayudar a los pobres o
nos ponemos al lado de los élites en
América Latina los que estaban al lado
de los élites han ganado Y eso ha
abierto la puerta a justamente a los
evangélicos
sí Bueno yo pienso que es mucho más Útil
es decir que no es que ratzinger sea el
papa conservador y que la caricatura que
a veces de la que a veces hemos abusado
los medios yo es más bien los la
corriente conservadora de la iglesia ha
querido apropiarse del Papa Benedicto 16
diciendo cosas que él no decía no como
que acabas de mencionar este Obispo
salas salas este que hay una portada del
libro donde decía por su autoría de él y
del Papa Benedicto 16 y además ponían
Papa Benedicto 16 y después El Vaticano
tuvo que desmentir que en realidad no
había escrito nada el Papa Benedicto XVI
Entonces es mucho más complejo es decir
están precisamente como decía My Love
los que quieren regresar a la antigua
misa antes del Vaticano segundo y yo
pienso yo no sé qué tanto realmente Es
cierto que el Papa Benedicto 16 estuvo
tan triste como dice su secretario
personal o cuando hubo este motus previo
porque Porque muchos le hacen decir al
papa al papa emérito cosas que quizás
nunca dijo claro Hay mucha hay muchas
que denuncian cierta caricaturización
como estamos viendo Mari lord de lucha
entre bandos que ni Francisco era tan
aperturista en cuestión o es tan
aperturista en cuestiones troncales y
que fue precisamente ratzinger quien
hizo buenos diagnósticos de lo que
sucedió en la iglesia bueno ratzinger
sin duda pasará como uno de los grandes
intelectuales que hemos tenido no solo
de la Iglesia También de la del siglo XX
No sí era un gran intelectual y tiene
este genio de del pueblo alemán es decir
esta capacidad en tomar perspectiva
tener un pensamiento muy filosófico
siempre quiso relacionar la fe y la
religión era una articulación muy
importante en su pensamiento y claro ahí
hubo muchas caricaturas por ejemplo él
estuvo siempre a favor de para él la
doctrina social de la iglesia es muy
importante no hay paz sin justicia
social eso siempre lo dijo y Francisco
también hay caricaturas y quizás
esperanzas que que no sean fundadas
porque él no va a cambiar la doctrina Yo
pienso lo que cambian en el estilo y el
método de Francisco
corresponsales Roma Federico Francisco
deberá lidiar en Soledad con las
amenazas que continúan llegando desde el
seno de la institución y terminar las
grandes reformas que prometió cuando
hace 10 años sucedió a Joseph racinger
cuáles son sus prioridades en lo que le
queda de papado cuando fue elegido El
Trece de marzo de 2013 casi 10 años
atrás
Papa Francisco dijo estas palabras muy
lindas Cómo me gustaría una iglesia
pobre y para los pobres yo creo que la
pobreza sigue siendo una prioridad para
Francisco la otra es el tema de la paz
en el mundo la guerra de Putin que Papa
Francisco muchas veces
definió y repitió como guerra repuñante
guerra repulsiva es un tema que lo lo
amargó muchísimo Entonces yo diría que
las prioridades son las prioridades de
la doble p paz y pobreza y son
prioridades para él más importantes aún
de los digamos de la guerra del poder de
los conflictos de todo lo que está
pasando y que pasará en el Vaticano y en
la misma institución
paz y pobreza como objetivos de lo que
estoy de acuerdo se llama Francisco no y
siempre lo ha explicado este que es para
no olvidarse de los pobres y además él
viene de la teología del de la pobreza
del pueblo que es una pequeña rama de la
de la teología de la liberación Entonces
yo Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con el
corresponsal y las reformas que ha
tenido que hacer el orden que ha tenido
que poner en el Vaticano eso es pues
porque es el patrón de la iglesia pero
totalmente de acuerdo en esos dos
aspectos vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa
en este punto y a vuelta vamos a seguir
analizando si les parece cómo ha ido
robando el terreno los evangélicos a la
iglesia católica en Latinoamérica será
vuelta de pausa que en Primera Plana
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y Franz 24.com
el mundo evoluciona cada vez más rápido
las noticias no esperan me gusta Francia
24 horas porque nos enteramos de las
noticias de Europa de América Latina y
de todos lados nos gusta mucho la
cultura francesa France 24 siempre
estará a su lado para comprender el
mundo para ofrecer la mejor información
internacional
24 horas del día en cualquier
circunstancia
France 24 en todo lugar y cada momento
con usted
Seguimos aquí en Primera Plana hablando
del presente y del futuro del Vaticano a
partir de la muerte del Papa Benedicto
16 de ratzinger Y de lo que le quede de
papado a Francisco que antecedente puede
suponer el tema de los dos papás
eméritos antes de irnos a la pausa
estábamos comentando la pérdida de
terreno que había sufrido la Iglesia
Católica en América Latina la mía Cómo
ha ido en los últimos años robando ese
terreno su evangélicos a la iglesia
católica en América Latina Qué factores
explican Este cambio progresivo es un
proceso que ha empezado hace como 40
años digamos en los 80 a medida que hay
una
una Urbanización cada vez más importante
de América Latina la gente sale de las
zonas Rurales donde hay apoyo de la
iglesia y también de las familias y
llegan a zonas totalmente vacías donde
es muy poco presente donde hay mucha
violencia donde hay muchos problemas y
donde la iglesia católica de manera muy
sencilla no está entonces en el inicio
no es que la gente no quiere ir a la
iglesia católica sino que la iglesia
católica no es presente en estos lugares
hay las iglesias porque no hay una
iglesia justamente evangélica tiene una
plasticidad de una capacidad de de ir en
todos la las todas las frentes
millonarias sea la amazonia de hecho o
sea por ejemplo en Brasil o sea estás
estos suburbios y ahí son espacios donde
encuentran de hecho una ayuda social
amistades son lugares donde otra vez no
hay el estado Entonces si uno necesita
que alguien lo ayude con los hijos la
iglesia lo hace uno te ayuda con la
comida la iglesia lo hace
uno canta juntos porque uno cuando
vuelve de todo el día de trabajo no hay
nada para hacer ahí después de 4 horas
de transporte como es el caso hablamos
de tejido social de funciones de tejido
social donde no está el estado o donde
los donde no está la iglesia católica
con lo cual hoy ya la imagen de una
América Latina católica es insostenible
en países Bueno hasta como Brasil
llegamos a 30 probablemente 35 40 por
ciento de la población y sin hablar de
amigas central donde en muchos casos
pasa casi a la mayoría ya he hecho el
diagnóstico les pregunto Ivonne maridor
Y cómo vuelve a recuperar la iglesia ese
tejido social que ha perdido en América
Latina cómo yo creo que hay varias
estrategias o actitudes y Francisco por
ser jesuita tiene esta esta facultad en
tener ambas cosas es decir una alianza
de estrategia y también de actitud
cristiana Es decir es lo que quiere lo
que hace y es muy inteligente también es
proponer fraternidad con los evangélicos
es algo que siempre
también fue muy inteligente organizar
las jornadas internacionales de la
juventud en Río porque porque justamente
esto permitió dar otra imagen de la
Iglesia Católica más dinámica y más
abierta también al diálogo
ecuménico con los evangélicos Ivonne
Cómo recuperar el terreno Pues en
realidad este los católicos inspiran
mucho de los movimientos evangélicos
este lo que se llama digamos la
renovación carismática hay muchísimos
cursos del espíritu santo porque fueron
los los hermanos cristianos por decir
así que redescubrieron que el espíritu
santo estaba presente y entonces
organizan muchísimas actividades y
muchísima gente va o sea incluso aquí en
París hay una hay una iglesia en que
reúne miles de personas cada jueves y
van y es una misa católica pero
inspirada con pues rituales y se puede
decir así o canciones este que vienen de
los de los evangélicos o de los
pentecostales porque efectivamente hay
varias Iglesias
Yo pienso que hay un terreno que está
totalmente perdido que ya no se va a
recuperar y recuperable hay ciudades
cerca de Río donde donde la gente está a
70 80 por ciento evangélica estamos a la
segunda a la tercera generación entonces
voy a contar muy rápidamente una
anécdota en Río justamente yo estaba
trabajando ahí como corresponsal había
la jornada de la Mundial de la Juventud
Y
cerraron básicamente Copacabana para que
todos estos católicos que venían del
mundo Pues yo pusieran estar así ahí fue
preguntar a gente evangélica que
trabajaba en Copacabana que no podía
entrar si estaban molestos con todo eso
y muchos me dijeron pero quién es este
tipo o sea Quién es el papa estamos
hablando del país más grande católico
del mundo y muchos no es que estaban en
contra como yo pensaba sino que ni
sabían conocimiento totalmente entonces
llegamos a eso no es más un tema de
enfrentamiento claro es de ignorancia
Total ya no hace parte de su vida
tremendamente cómo ilustra a veces una
anécdota así ilustrada desde luego sin
duda un tema mucho se ha hablado
volvemos con nosotros con
responsabilidad mucho se ha hablado de
la relación entre ambos papás para
muchos la relación se
ha salido se rompió hace dos años aunque
muchos analistas afirman que sí que
sintonizaban entre ellos mucho mejor de
lo que la prensa ha querido señalar
Federico Cómo ha sido esa convivencia
podría Francisco seguir los pasos de
dado el antecedente Y retirarse si la
salud no le da Papa Francisco y Papa
Benedicto emérito eran el sol y la luna
en realidad el primero viene argentino
latinoamericano un Papa de los abrazos
un papa que le gustaba el fútbol que le
gusta el fútbol que dice siempre lo que
piensa en cambio el autor era un Papa
bien alemán europeo tocaba el piano
escribía lo que pensaba dos papas
Opuestos nueve años de diferencia pero
siempre mantuvieron una relación muy
linda entre los dos Papa Francisco dos o
tres veces repitió que para él Papa
Benedicto era como tener un abuelo sabio
cerca de su casa un Nono Sancho y el
mismo Benedicto nunca apoyó digamos a la
hinchada de los conservadores contra
Francisco
Qué pasará con Francisco lo sabe solo él
es la decisión más importante de su vida
es un Papa de personalidad Así que yo
creo que elbas va a decidir lo que
quiera decidir cualquier cosa que le
digan sus amigos sus colaboradores va a
usar su cabeza como siempre la está
usando así que no podemos saber lo que
va a hacer
Por cierto que se espera con atención la
próxima visita del papá Congo y Sudán
del sur con un programa anclado en La
Paz lo que recuerda a otros viajes del
papel declaraciones sobre conflictos
abiertos en el mundo Francisco ha
viajado más que otros papás no sé si
podemos decir que esta es una de sus
marcas del papado marilón los viajes sí
es un papa que desde que llegó dijo en
2013 que había que llevar el mensaje
evangélico a las periferias de la
iglesia y también es un papá que se
desplaza mucho cuando fue arzobispo de
Buenos Aires tomaba el metro y no tenía
auto no tenía guarda especial es alguien
es también es una persona que le gusta
la experiencia empírica es un hombre del
encuentro le gusta arremangarse Las
mangas e ir a ver al pueblo a hablar con
él Entonces sí es un papá que le gusta
desplazarse a pesar de lo que dijo en
cualquier caso hablamos de viajes ahora
Estamos bien Vamos a ver una de viajes
en África se habla de que un posible
sucesor podría llegar de Asia o de
África no sé si son también intentos del
Vaticano de llegar de entender cómo
funciona el mundo cómo funcionan también
las claves demográficas del planeta y
buscar nuevos graneros de fieles Yo
pienso que es eso también un falso
debate es decir cuando se juntan para
escoger un nuevo papa es bueno piden la
que el espíritu santo
y en realidad Incluso un Papa africano
quizás Sería más conservador que un Papa
este alemán o argentino etcétera
entonces yo pienso que la nacionalidad
no tiene No
para mí sí
lamia encontramos que además los
evangélicos se han convertido estábamos
comentando antes de los factores en un
codiciado público para los candidatos
políticos ahora llena en América Latina
parece que cualquier candidato que se
parece una campaña electoral tiene que
diseñar su programa atendiendo a ese
público y a ese público las campañas de
la región ya están pensando en esas
coordenadas de evangélicas sí Bueno hay
países donde es más marcados
y tiene que ver con el sistema político
con partidos muy débiles con una
fragmentación muy grande eso tiene un
peso pero de manera muy sencilla cuando
hay 30-40% de la población que que es
evangélica eso pesa son más jóvenes el
papel del pastor en lo que votan
Aparentemente tiene más peso porque
también van más al templo que que los
católicos y los pastores supieron
usar todo eso para crear una dinámica
política incluso la iglesia más grande
que es la universal tiene su propio
partido que es el partido republicano
bueno es así y que tiene una eficiencia
muy grande para elegir a la gente y lo
que pasa es que pasamos de un momento
que no muy marcado izquierda derecha de
hecho votar lo votaron a Lula en general
las dos primeras veces hasta Dilma ahora
una agenda que es captada esencialmente
por la derecha tal vez tiene que ver con
varias cosas que podemos hablar pero
también por el hecho que la derecha es
más fuerte de manera general tiene una
agenda mucho más fuerte y no es solo con
los evangélicos el sector Ultra
conservador libró en los últimos años
una batalla sin cuartel contra Francisco
a quien acusaron de hereje y llegaron a
pedir su renuncia Benedicto sin embargo
funcionaba también como una suerte de
escudo Cómo enfrentar a Francisco esta
etapa sin su escudo
es un reto para él afrontar esa
corriente sin tener a quien le defendía
yo creo que va a usar una cualidad de
efecto que tiene y que él confiesa es su
autoritarismo no lo digo yo
que incluso su secreta su su
bueno su colaborador en Buenos Aires
decía que tenía esta actitud de hacer
autoritario Bueno es que fue
provincial jesuita de Argentina es decir
que tiene una experiencia de liderar de
cómo liderar también y liderar en la
tormenta porque fue provincial durante
la dictadura Así que yo creo que va a
ser una una estrategia una un arma que
va a usar Por cierto me quedo ya sin
tema pero les quiero preguntar entre los
retos futuros que le quedan en lo que le
queda el papa de Francisco a la hora de
buscar nuevos graneros de fieles y va a
decir devotos bueno devotos infieles
claro hay que estudiar cuestiones
demográficas pero no sé si también la
iglesia puede dar estos avances por
ejemplo respecto a las mujeres el
sacerdocio de mujeres que se ha
especulado con ese tema muchas veces
marilón necesitó la cabeza como diciendo
no eso no podría ser yo creo que de este
tema lo va a evolucionar no va a cambiar
las cosas en cambio sí que se van a
integrar mucho más a las mujeres en
cargos de alta responsabilidad y ya es
el caso hace 10 años desde que Francisco
ha sido elegido papa que ya este proceso
se se ve hay 30% más de mujeres que
ahora tienen altos cargos en la curia y
otro retos que le quedan completar las
grandes reformas como la puesta en
marcha de la nueva constitución
apostólica no que era una de En qué
consiste esto no sé si lo podemos
explicar brevemente muy breve muy breve
marylor muy bueno es una forma de una
refundación de la organización de la
curia nos dedica estéreos que son los
ministerios se ven como servicios hace
sentiste mucho en esta palabra de
servicio porque el Papa Francisco quiere
luchar contra el carrerismo para ello va
a desarrollar más colaboración entre los
laicos y también
la jerarquía para que haya más
horizontalidad y menos verticalidad y
una cosa muy importante también es que
se crea un giga estéreo de la Caridad
nos quedamos ya sin tiempo muy
interesante Muchísimas gracias a las
tres lamia Ivonne y a nuestro
corresponsal en Roma Federico Google ha
sido muy interesante hablar de este
nuevo ciclo que se abre en el Vaticano
Muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes y
hasta la próxima semana quien en Primera
Plana gracias